>>> SO THIS IS BREIN
I G  TOFY CT COMMITTEE
IEVE THAT THWEA CRIMINAL CONSPIO
OVERTURNHE0
ELECTION.I BRING IN N'S  LEGALFR
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG.
PAULA I'M  WITH AT THEY
LIUMP AND OTHERSNNECTED TO HIS .
WHYOU KNOW T
REOUGH THI
COMMITTEE REVEALING THT
BELIEVES THAT FORMTRUMP AND ONES
IT BELIEVES THAT TRUMP A MITTE
HE S AND
THEY LT  OERCRIMES INCLUDI OL P
O E , AWS RTF
S TOUB, ALS T
OF A FILING IN A CASE
TRYING TON
E-MAIL CONSERVATIVE LAWYER
JO EASTMAN.
WE KNOW 'VNG  SEEN SR OFY'VE LET
ENW THEY'VE TAEDO
REDS OF WITNESSES.
BUT TO WHAT
AND HEREY GIVEWINDOW, THMO EXTEE
FATLWHFOUND, WHAT
NO C
ANYONE.ARGED WITE .NOT CHARGE
BUT THEY SIGNAL IN THIS LI
MAKE CRIMINA
FIND IN THRESTTHIS
ITT OF THIS COTEU HEARD WHAT PAD
I ,  DEAL.WHAT HAPPENS NOW?CAE
ISN'S PAULA POINTE'T CHARGED HE,
SO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THIS.
THIS IS NOT A CRIMIN
HOWEVER, WHAT IT IS  A
CO CONGRES IGOING ON.SENSE THE
WEO GET E E-MAILS
T PRIVILEGED.
PRIVILEGED.MMUNICATIONS AN ATTO
T NOT IF THEY TEO A
E-MAILS LAFRAUD, SO WETHOSE E-M.
BUT BIDO
A CALL TO ACTION
THE TELLING
DOJ WE THINK THERE'ST LEENOU YOU
BE TAKING A RYK D HE'S CASE AS A
TENTIAL CRIMINAL FRAUD
AND OBSTRU
>> ELIE, THE FILING INCLUDESN I
PRESIDT PES COCHG NDN EASTMAN.S
NG, "AND
THANKS T OUT, E R SIEGE."
ICRN IR E>> YEAH.TMAN'S
LEGAL THEORY, LET'S PUT SCARE
THAT, TH TVI P ITHORITY TO SIMP
Y BUT IT AUAD
KNEW THAT THERE WAS NO BASISEN J
THOSTES.
THAT IT ONALD TRUM
ND SIT
HAIDD UM
EVN EASTMAN KNOWLE
PRLOST AND THAT VICE ONY THAT
SIS O
HOWEVEASTMAN O THE EFFORT
TO OVERTUR
O WITHHOLD
E-MAILS UNDEATTORN
PRIVILEGE.
THE E-MAILS.
MOREM THE FILI,  SAYS
ENON
AVAIBLHE COMMI ISHES
THAT TERS MAY  AND/OR
FRAUDULENT ACTD THAT
PLAINTIFF'S LEGAL AS
A CONVINCINES.
>>Y DO IN ORDER TO
PIL OF
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE, DON.
AND A IEIN JN TT
EASTMAN AND DONALD TRUMPARE
COMMUNRDE HOSE
TRUMPMAN OSTHE LINE.ION TO POAE
COUNTITHE FRAUD TRYING TO STEALM